if you were designing a religion would
you include physical laws or physical
forces is it necessary and sufficient to
have a creation of the universe as part
of your religion and a creation of a
personal relationship with God I think
it's very important to recognize that
there are multiple ways of being a
scientist who happens to be religious
and I've learned this over time so I've
been wrong on this topic and I've in
coming into contact with higher quality
scientists motivated by religion I've
come to understand that there's a sub
population that is very special and
interesting and it's effectively a
population of people who agreed to the
rules of science they're not going to
cheat on the rules of science because
Jesus but they are going to use the idea
of purpose and a personal relationship
with God to give them courage to
question things that are essentially
unquestionable
[Music]